now here's another powerful champion for
the environment and a u.n goodwill
ambassador since 2005 he and his band
have eliminated over 120 million pounds
of co2 and half a million single-use
plastic bottles from their shows
here with the performance he recorded
especially for countdown
is dave matthews
hello uh i'm dave matthews and i was
invited to play a song
thank you for having me i was also
invited to say
something about climate change although
i'm confident that those who are
qualified have already
said all that needs to be said
but it does seem to be by far the
biggest problem
facing humanity facing the world
and uh
and we certainly have to do something
about it we have to do everything about
it it should be everything we think
about
and then i also think about the fact
that if every fish and every bird and
every flower and every tree and every
human and every little critter
if all of it vanished
and left a dead
planet that was once once beautiful and
blue
it wouldn't
not even the moon would notice
the stars certainly wouldn't miss us
just be a speck of dust that never was
and
maybe that's a comfort
this song's called dive in and i hope
it's appropriate
[Music]
i saw a man on the side of the road with
a sign that red
i will work for food
so i tried to look busy
until the light turned green
and i saw a bear on tv
cause his friends were all drowning
see their homes were turning to water
[Music]
a strange kind of sad big old
[Music]
wake up sleepy head i think the sun's a
little brighter today smile and watch
the icicles melt away
see the water rise and summers here to
stay and that sweet summer breeze will
blow forever go down to the shore get
off your shoes dive in the empty ocean
you tell me
everything will be
okay if i just stay on my knees and keep
praying
believing in something
you tell me
everything is all taken care of by those
qualified to take care of it all
they take care of it
so wake up
sleepyhead i think the sun's a little
brighter today smiling watch the icicles
melt away
see the water rise in summers here to
stay and all those summer games will
last forever go down to the shore kick
off your shoes dive in the empty ocean
someday
you think we'll wake up
in a world
on its way to getting better and if so
can you tell me
i have been thinking
that lately
the blood is increasing
the tourniquet's not keeping hold
in spite of our twisting
though we would love to believe that we
are we are not in control
though we would love to believe
yeah
wake up
sleepyhead i think the sun's a little
brighter today smile and watch the
icicles melt away
see the waters rise in summers in a
stand all those summer girls will dance
forever go down to the shore kick off
your shoes dive in the empty ocean